vamos a hacer en este vídeo algunos
ejemplos de multiplicación con el método
de rejillas entonces en el siguiente
vídeo voy a mostrar por qué funciona el
método de rejillas entonces digamos que
tenemos 27 x 48 y voy a escribir el 27
así baja el 2 y el 7 tendrán distintas
columnas y el 48 lo escribo en la
derecha así ahora voy a dibujar las las
rejillas que por eso se le llama el
método de rejillas entonces el 2 y el 7
tendrán su propia columna y el 4 y el 8
tendrán su propia fila ahora bien lo
divertido del método de rejillas es que
multiplicas todo y ya después sumas
entonces no tienes que andar cargando o
bueno de hecho si cargas pero eso ya es
cuando estás sumando ahora voy a dibujar
aquí estas estas diagonales y ya en el
siguiente vídeo voy a mostrarte por qué
funcionan entonces ya estamos listos
para multiplicar así que vamos 7 por 4
es es igual a 28 pongo
aquí y el 8 acá ahora 2 x 4 es igual a 8
entonces pongo un 0 aquí y el 8 acá
abajo 7 por 8 es igual a 56 entonces 7
por 8 es igual a 56 entonces por 15 aquí
y un 6 acá ahora finalmente 2 por 8 es
igual a 16 pongo un 1 aquí y 16 acá ya
terminamos la multiplicación ahora vamos
a sumar todo esto entonces lo que haces
es usar las diagonales como como
referencia en esta diagonal tenemos aquí
a los dígitos que están en las unidades
simplemente tenemos al 6 y pongo el 6
ahí ahora vamos con el siguiente con la
siguiente diagonal que sería este que
contiene al 6 al 5 y al 8 y simplemente
sumas 8 5 es igual a 13 y 13 6 es igual
a 19 pongo al 9 aquí en el lugar de las
décimas y llevamos 1 lo pongo el 1 aquí
el 1 ya está en el lugar de la gente
nace entonces esto no es un 19 es un 190
en fin a simplemente sumando de esta
diagonal
aquí tenemos uno más dos es igual a tres
más ocho es igual a once más uno es
igual a doce
entonces pongo el dos en el lugar de las
centenas y llevamos uno ajá entonces
simplemente 10 es igual a 1 así que esto
la respuesta 27 por 48 es igual a 1.296
eso es magia verdad entonces hagamos
otro otro problema con un poco con unos
unos cuantos dígitos más y ya verás que
la multiplicación con el método de de
rejillas funciona excelente para con
cualquier problema no importa cuántos
dígitos sean supongamos que tenemos aquí
vamos a multiplicar cinco mil 479 por
787 ajá entonces voy a poner cuatro
columnas una para cada uno de estos
dígitos entonces tenemos una para el 5
otra para
4 otro para el 7 otra para el 9 entonces
tenemos 5 mil 479 y x 787 cada uno de
esos números con su propia fila ajá así
que ahora vamos a dibujar las rejas
vamos a dibujar aquí las las filas y las
columnas una columna otra columna así y
ahora vamos con las filas para que no se
escapen entonces aquí
si las filas y ahora vamos con con las
diagonales entonces una diagonal aquí
otra diagonal acá otra diagonal creo que
ya entiende es aquí el método entonces
es otra diagonal y las últimas dos
diagonales ahora ya estamos listos para
multiplicar entonces multipliquemos así
que vamos con esto 9 por 7 es igual a 63
pongo el 6 aquí el 3 acá 7 por 7 es
igual a 49 4 por 7 es igual a 28 5 por 7
es igual a 35 y después vamos a voy a
cambiar de color acá para estas
multiplicaciones en esta fila 9 por 8 es
igual a 72 7 por 8 es igual a 56 4 por 8
es igual a 32 5 por 8 es igual a 40
40 ahora otra vez cambio de color
entonces 9 por 7 es igual a 63 7 por 7
si ya lo hicimos es igual a 49 4 por 7
es igual a 28 y 5 por 7 es igual a 35 y
atril terminamos ya con la
multiplicación ahora vamos a cambiar sus
cerebros a modo suma y vamos a sumar voy
a poner la suma en color qué color será
bueno el rosa el rosa siempre es bueno
así que sumemos tenemos aquí un 3 en el
lugar de las unidades ahora vamos con
las escenas entonces 2 + 6 es igual a
889 es igual a 17 pongo el 7 aquí
llevamos 1 ahora uno más 3 es igual a 4
y 4 más 7 es igual a 11 11 + 6 es igual
a 17 y 17 más 4 es igual a 21 y 21 más 8
es igual a 29 entonces pongo el 9
y llevamos dos en el lugar de las de las
centenas perdón de las decenas no perdón
sí de las centenas de las centenas ahora
me confundo ahora no dos más seis es
igual a ocho más 9 es igual a 17 más 5
es igual a 22 y 24 26 más 5 es igual a
31 ya llevamos 3 ahora 3 más 4 es igual
a 7 más 8 es igual a 15 más 13 es igual
a 18 y 18 + 0 es igual a 18 18 más 3 es
igual a 21 ajá entonces llevamos
llevamos 2 2 más 2 es igual a 4 + 5 es
igual a 9 más 4 es igual a 13 y ahora
uno más 3 es igual a 4 y ya terminamos
ahora que hay dos ventajas en el método
de rejillas nos brinda dos ventajas una
una de ellas es que hicimos las
multiplicaciones separadas de la de la
suma entonces lo hace un poco más
sencillo
otra vez que es bastante limpio este
método aunque de hecho bueno si usa
mucho espacio pero veo sea todo está en
su fila y en su columna y todo eso y
obtuvimos la respuesta a la respuesta es
4 millones 311 mil 973 y ya ahora en el
siguiente vídeo vamos a mostrar por qué
funciona este método